[Applause]
thanks very much uh and good morning
it's a pleasure to be here
today I want to set up my Reflections on
three key parts of my portfolio as
culture secretary
they are potential
opportunity
and freedom
that is unlocking the potential that
exists in the industries my department
represents including the creative
Industries
ensuring dcms and government as a whole
supports opportunities for young people
I'm thirdly highlighting the challenges
to press freedom and identifying the
principles by which we need to resolve
those challenges
before I turn to those thoughts I want
to spend a moment talking about delivery
because you will know that we have a
prime minister who is laser focused on
delivery
and he appointed me a hundred days ago
to deliver on a number of projects that
affect our communities
and I've taken that challenge to deliver
very seriously
in that time I brought to fruition a
number of previous commitments
they include a draft Media bill with
reforms to level the playing field for
our Public Service broadcasters
a football white paper to protect our
beautiful game
a gambling white paper that delivers for
the smartphone age
millions of pounds to support youth
facilities across the country
a hundred million pounds to support our
Charities and 60 million pounds to
upgrade our swimming pools
an international Summit setting out our
opposition to Russian and belarussian
participation in international sporting
events
as well as working with my department
the royal family and the BBC to deliver
the coronation and the events
surrounding it
as well as Eurovision where we worked
very closely with Liverpool
and now that I've delivered on those
commitments I want to lay out a clear
agenda for the months ahead
once entered around potential
opportunity and freedom
and I wanted to start by telling you a
story
about an absolutely brilliant woman
called Yeta who understood the
importance of freedom opportunity and
potential
her parents were Russian and came to our
free country as refugees fleeing
persecution
and despite a number of potential
drawbacks of that age being Jewish being
a child of immigrants and being a woman
she succeeded
yetter ignored obstacles and focused
instead on the opportunity she had been
given to be brought up here in the UK
and in her very own extensive potential
my grandmother yet a Fraser became the
first female Barrister in Leicester and
practiced at the bar until she was 80.
and on every visit I made to see her
she reminded me of a line in a poem by
Robert Browning
a man's reach should exceed his grasp
or what's the heaven for
it's a line about believing in your
ability to succeed and take advantage of
the opportunity to realize your
potential
it totally summed up her life
and it's my guiding principle in this
role
my department gets to represent some of
the very best of Britain
musicians and songwriters like Adele and
Ed Sheeran world-class footballers
budding Young Writers and producers
video game creators and fashion
designers
to my mind dcms is a department for
talent and opportunity
and our Industries are truly world class
I represent so many companies that have
understood their potential and done
everything possible to maximize it I
just wanted to take two examples from
companies here in this room
Skye who launched in 1989 in a prefab
structure in an industrial park in the
fringes of West London today's sky is
among our leading entertainment
companies with 23 million subscribers
or Netflix
who was founded as a mail order rental
firm in the 90s and have evolved into a
business that spent 4.8 billion pounds
in the UK in the last three years alone
making TV shows and films here and
kickstarting long-term Studio leases at
shepparton longcross and a New London
headquarters opening last year
indeed our creative Industries are world
class
they generated 108 billion pounds
in 2021 they employ over 2 million
people across the country and to put
things in perspective they are worth
more than our life sciences Automotive
manufacturing Aerospace and the oil and
gas sectors
combined
we are in the global age of the Silver
Screen
we rival any country in the world at
sound and visual effects and are on
track to double UK film Sage Space by
2025.
and there is world over demand for
high-end British Productions
not just because of our fantastic actors
and our great locations but because of
our Tech know-how and our production
skills the imagination of our designers
our producers our content creators our
writers and our artists the spearheading
growth right across our economy
but it's also owed in part to how
government and Industry have worked
together to back talent in this country
and make Britain one of the best places
in the world to be creative
and I am here to continue to maximize
that growing potential
this conservative government has shown
what can be achieved when we work with
and listen to all of you in industry
it's that same model of public-private
partnership that gave us a world-class
vaccine development program and roll out
right across the country they gave us a
1.5 billion pound covered relief package
during covid that protected our cultural
and creative Industries
and a highly successful film and TV
production restart scheme that ensured
the industry was able to continue making
great new content despite the lack of
commercial insurance to cover covid risk
also the tax reliefs that have been a
huge Catalyst for growth for our
creative Industries
and I have no doubt that we in
government can do more to support the
creatives
but we can't simply rely on the past
formula for that past success
you will know that we Face increasing
Global competition and we can't afford
to be complacent by turbocharging growth
and investment in sectors like video
games visual effects music fashion film
and television and more we can retain
our status as a creative industry's
superpower for decades to come
in order to do that
we need to maximize potential
so I am committing
to Growing the creative industries by an
extra 50 billion pounds by 2030.
creating a million extra jobs all over
the country by 2030. I'm delivering a
creative careers promise that builds a
pipeline of talent into our creative
Industries
and I want to work with you to deliver
it
and I know we can
because we are fortunate to have a prime
minister and a chancellor who have
identified this sector
as one of five priority sectors for
government and to have shown their
commitment by taking action to support
the industry
at the budget the chancellor backed our
theaters our museums galleries
orchestras film high-end TV and video
game sectors by extending and reforming
tax reliefs that create jobs Drive
growth and support Talent
over the next few months we will be
identifying how we can go even further
first growing these sectors by promoting
skills from primary school children to
those returning to the workforce whether
that's in music at school or
extracurricular activities
and working with the creative sector on
maximizing the opportunities of boot
camps and apprenticeships
secondly we want to harness talent in
clusters across the UK
and support can't be at the expense of
London or detract from those places that
are already thriving it needs to build
on what we have already seen across the
country whether that's video games in
Dundee and lamington spa or TV in
Birmingham and Leeds
and thirdly
targeting specific support at different
sub-sectors to unlock growth across the
UK
and now I'd like to turn to opportunity
particularly for young people
because we need inspired empowered and
creative people to drive these
industries forward in the future
and I want to ensure that young people
wherever they are and whatever their
backgrounds are
they have the opportunity to realize
their potential
and their dreams just like Yetta did
for something better than the probable
Destiny of their background
before taking up this role in dcms I was
responsible for youth Justice
I met many young people who had
unfortunately gone down the wrong path
none of them intending or really wanting
to
I remember meeting John who'd struggled
at school
dropped out of school
and then been sent to a young offenders
Institution
he said to me I don't really understand
why no one realized that I was
struggling and that I needed help I
don't really understand why no one
noticed me
through a mentoring support scheme after
he came out of prison he got back on
track and he himself became a mentor to
other young children
we already have the National Youth
guarantee but I plan to expand that and
offer and make Central youth to how we
do things as a department
we need to offer all young children
inspiration aspiration
of fulfilling education hope
and support
and finally freedom
as a descendant of someone who had to
flee persecution for freedom
I appreciate what it means to live in a
free Society
and how dangerous it is when those
freedoms are threatened
organizations in this room today play a
vital role in protecting both our
freedoms and our democracy
we often talk about freedom of the press
but the reality is that it's you the
media who are helping to protect the
freedom of others you who live up to the
words of George Orwell inscribed by his
statue outside BBC broadcasting house
it's if Liberty means anything at all it
means the right to tell people what they
do not want to hear
and I recognize that this basic right is
under threat across the world
the New York Times chairman told UNESCO
earlier this month that all over the
world independent journalists oppressed
freedoms are under attack
and he was right
because you only need to look at the
Russian arrest of a Wall Street Journal
journalist to see that
I know that the challenge is to feed to
free
fair and truthful reporting are coming
from so many quarters
from the potential use misuse of AI to
miss and disinformation
and and that is even without mentioning
the speed of the changing media
landscape
staying competitive in a rapidly
changing environment is a challenge for
everyone Challenger companies like
BuzzFeed and vice that were once the New
Kids on the Block are facing uncertain
futures
as a government we are taking steps to
increase press freedoms and make sure
that journalists can do their jobs
effectively
with measures like the protection of
Public Service broadcasters and
prominence in the draft Media bill
and our commitment to repeal section 40
or the protection of journalists in the
Online safety bill we are actively
guarding your ability to uphold the
rights of others
if we want to have a thriving media
sector in the future
our Focus has to be on a free press
and a press that is free to grow
I know that that is a major focus of
your discussions today looking at what
the future looks like for companies big
and small
and through on the draft Media bill we
are updating a decades-old regulatory
framework to level the playing field
and help guarantee the long-term future
of those first-class Public Service
broadcasters
whilst also giving a broadcaster like
Channel 4 even greater freedoms to
produce own and sell outstanding British
content across the globe
no government has all the answers to all
the challenges that the media faces
but what I can promise you is that my
Approach will be guided by the following
principles
protecting our Public Service
broadcasters
standing up for independent voices and
nurturing a thriving media landscape
which upholds and champions Fearless
truth-telling
to finish I want to end on a thought
last Saturday I enjoyed seeing the
amazing cultural program organized by
Liverpool as the host City for
Eurovision song contest which showcased
Ukrainian artists
I also celebrated through 7 000 others
in the Liverpool Arena at the Grand
Final
creative excellence TV production at its
finest world-class BBC output
I was sitting next to the Ukrainian
culture minister
and as the show started
Russia bombed Ukraine
he turned to me and said
it's surreal
he looked around at the glitter the
spectacle
and the sparkle
and he said
I am here
and my wife is in a bomb shelter in
Ukraine
here in the UK
we are lucky to have it all
potential opportunity
freedom and we must embrace it
because as my grandmother would have
said
what's a heaven for
thank you
secretary of state that was a wonderful
projection of your personal
passion and the backstory to it and I
think for everyone in the room a very
personal call to action around potential
opportunity and freedom and what you see
this industry offering so thank you for
that and I've got a couple of questions
and I may be able to come very quickly
to the audience but I'm in the red on
the time box but I'd like to ask some if
you had one highlight from your first
100 days or so in office what would it
be
so I think the Highlight must be the
last week because we've had a
combination in the last week of uh how
brilliant we are on the world stage and
that is the coronation which was a
combination of sharing our excellence in
the world of 200 foreign dignitaries
here
um we had you know world-class creative
content in the music
as well as Eurovision where we had you
know creative Excellence as well and I
think sometimes we undersell ourselves
as the UK across the world they're
always looking to us to leaders and I
was so proud over the course of the last
week to be British that's wonderful and
do you think I'm switching that the
creative Industries get the
credit that they deserve for the
economic heavyweight sector that you
described I
do now I think we have a prime minister
as I mentioned and a chancellor who
totally understand the power of the
creative Industries and and so they
should I mean they're um
they they're double the rate they're
growing at Double the rate of the rest
of the economy and so they're they're an
absolute superpower and we need to
support them and we are doing so whether
that's through tax reliefs you know
ensuring that we have the pipeline of
skills but I think now
um I'm very lucky to be in this post
because I think we have a prime minister
and a Chancellor to whom the door is
open so I think you know if we come up
with uh the right plan I think we've got
a government that is absolutely
listening to the power of this sector
okay now let me just go to the floor is
there any are there any questions from
the floor we've got one over here let me
in this piece can we have a mic please
and for our time Keepers we will keep it
brief do we have a microphone
I think the microphone is on its way
at speed thank you microphone
thanks thank you it's uh Jill Hein from
Ender's analysis uh do you think
traditional Public Service broadcasters
can compete in the age of the streaming
Giants
I do absolutely I think
um I think both have something to offer
and I think that uh for example you know
the BBC and ITV are doing something very
different to Netflix and Disney uh say
you know BBC obviously
um has an obligation to do British
production for a British audience as
well as obviously uh the world service
but if you look at stats like for
instance there is a really interesting
stat that 69 of people
um have watched Netflix in the last year
and 75 or have used iPlayer you can see
that they can both survive in a very
competitive environment but if our job
as Government to ensure that we back
both that both can grow in the
competitive world that we have
fabulous we have time for one more
question I'll take in the middle please
the lady with
blonde hair waving
thank you and then we will for our time
Keepers then that will be the last
question thank you it's Kate bulkley you
mentioned in your speech
um AI this seems to be the theme that
we're going to talk about a lot today
even industry players are now calling
for regulation of AI how do you see this
happening how do you think it's going to
get formulated what role should
government play in this and how are you
going to coordinate it internationally
because it's again one of these issues
that it's not just UK I know that's a
big question but if you can give us some
views that would be great
time time that I have and
um so AI is what is both one of the
biggest challenges and the biggest
opportunity that comes that is coming
down the path and it's absolutely right
that we work both as a government with
industry and internationally to think
about these issues
um so decent um the department for
science innovation has already done a
report on AI and is of course looking at
regulation I'm very concerned as the
Secretary of State for culture media and
Sport to ensure that we protect original
creative Works whether that's in the
creative Industries whether that's news
we need to ensure that you get Fair
compensation for the work that you are
doing but this is something that we all
need to work together on there are
absolutely no easy answers to this
question and it's something that as a
government we're looking very very
closely at
thank you and Secretary of State thank
you we're sadly going to have to call
the questions to a close there